a Las Vegas man who gave a 17 year old
girl fatal fentanyl pills sentenced to
prison today it was one of the first
cases in southern Nevada where a dealer
was charged with murder for causing a
deadly fentanyl overdose a news now
investigator Kyle Payne was in the
courtroom for the emotional hearing
the judge in Clark County had her hands
full today having to decide between
punishing a drug dealer for an
unthinkable murder or taking it easy on
the middleman who perhaps couldn't have
foreseen what would have happened to
seventeen-year-old Mia Gugino in the end
the judge took the state's sentencing
recommendation he could serve four to
ten years for voluntary manslaughter and
drug dealing charges prosecutors say in
2021 Joshua Roberts gave Gugino a
Centennial High School soccer star what
she thought was Ecstasy but it was laced
with a fatal dose of fentanyl the
courtroom was packed with the victims
friends and family considerably more of
a showing than most murder sentencings
kindness and happiness
the prosecutor told Judge Michelle
Levitt today that Robert still hasn't
taken responsibility for killing gujino
Robert's lawyer disagreed with that she
had asked the judge to consider her
clients intent and the foreseeability of
what happened to gujino the victim in
this case kugino was supposed to play
soccer at the College of Southern Nevada
her father said their family is moving
out of state because he doesn't want to
be in the same city as a murderer Who
quote pushes poison on people